- - Je le répète, puis je vais
lele répéter tout le temps,
c'c'est important de rester
huhumble. C'est important à chae
jojour de mériter la confiance
dedes Québécois. Ce n'est jamais
gagagné pour toujours. Donc, pas
d'd'arrogance, on reste humble,
pupuis on écoute les Québécois.
- - Monsieur Legault, je vous ai
prprésenté cet extrait pour
momontrer qu'il a dit à ses
trtroupes de ne pas avoir l'ava-
dedernier la Coupe Stanley, ce
n'n'est qu'un match!
N'N'empêche que c'est une grosse
vivictoire pour la CAQ.
BoBonsoir à vous deux!
C'C'est une grosse défaite poure
PLPLQ, en 5, Place, et une grose
dédéfaite pour le PQ.
- - Deux gagnants, trois
peperdantes!
C'C'est une grosse victoire pour
MoMonsieur Legault, si on regare
lele candidat présenté par le P,
unune vedette comme Pierre Nant,
onon aurait pu s'attendre à ce e
çaça marche et on s'attendait àe
quque le PQ puisse peut-être
réréussir, surtout avec la semae
didifficile que Monsieur Legaula
eueue.
CeCela dit, ça fait un état des
lilieux à six mois des élection.
PoPour les parties de l'oppositn
ququi ont perdu, et vont devoir
rerevoir leur plan de match les
trtrois partis de l'opposition à
l'l'assemblée nationale n'ont ps
fafait l le poids devant Monsier
LeLegault, ils ont six mois pour
rerevoir la plan.
- - Il y a des alarmes qui
sosonnent!
- - Oui c'est alarmant, surtout
popour les Parti libéral.
Le PQ a quand même maintenu son
scscore, ça reste une perte
lolourde.
MaMais pour les libérauxux je pe
quque c'est encore plus
ininquiétant, 7 %, c'est vraimet
drdramatique.
DaDans l'ensemble du Québec
frfrancophone, ça veut dire que
leles libéraux sont presque excs
dede la course.
C'C'est un problème considérable
etet il y a un problème de
leleadership au Parti libéral, e
ququi m'a frappé, je ne sais pas
sisi vous avez remarqué, dans le
dedernier sondage Léger la moité
d'd'sélect libéraux voyaient en
MmMme Anglade la meilleure premr
miministre.
EtEt dans les autres parties
c'c'était différent, mais pour
MaMadame Anglade et Paul Saint-
PiPierre Plamondon, les électeus
dede leur parti le long font pas
coconfiance.
DoDonc il y a un gros problème.
- - Quand ça va si mal, moins de
QuQuand ça va si mal, moins de 7
%,%, c'est difficile de ne pas
reregarder les chefs la cheffe.
LuLuc commentaires?
- - Elle a tenté d'avoir un vote
plplus progressif et détendre sn
évéventail sur les francophonest
l'l'environnements, elle auraitû
rerester sur les votes
trtraditionnels et libéraux, mas
jeje ne suis pas d'accord, ce qi
ararrive au Parti libéral devait
ararriver, c'était le garde du
cocorps du fédéralisme.
LaLa deuxième raison, les grands
papartis s'effondrent, à juste u
QuQuébec, on l'a vu en France.
LeLes libéraux s'appuyaient sure
papatronat, les péquistes sur ls
sysyndicats, ce n'est plus comme
cecela!
NiNi ici ni en France, maintenat
c'c'est plus partagé entre les
paparties, la CAQ représente
bebeaucoup les patronat, mais
paparfois le syndicat.
LaLa CAQ et un gouvernement de
drdroite, il n'y a plus les mêms
lilignes de partage qu'avant.
- - Vous dîtes, on entend
bebeaucoup, il y a des libéraux
ququi nous parlent et qui nous
didisent qu'ils n'ont plus de
rerepères, on dirait que Mme
AnAnglade a peur de défendre le
cécégep Dawson, mais dans le fod
c'c'est plus profond?
- - Le message n'est pas clair
dadans le cas de Mme Anglade, ls
nanationalismes oui c'est très
bibien, mais aussitôt qu'on arre
dadans des cas concrets créés
cocomme la loi 21, on ne sait ps
trtrop où elle devrait être.
LeLe Parti libéral a dû faire un
vivirage progressiste au dernier
cocongrès, ils étaient plus à
gagauche que les solidaires.
EnEn environnement même chose, n
sese lance à 100 milliards dans
l'l'hydrogène vert.
JeJe pense que les libéraux sont
dédéboussolés et je comprends ce
quque Luc dit, des lignes de fod
onont beaucoup bougé en Occiden,
mamais il faut que le message st
clclair et le cas des libéraux e
l'l'est plus.
- - Aussi un problème qu'elle a
bibien identifié, elle parlait
bebeaucoup d'économies, exécutat
dede messages économiques ne
papassaient pas, et c'est vrai t
unune partie de son élève sera i
a a probablement voté en 2018 pr
elelle a voté pour la CAQ.
LaLa figure économique, image
écéconomique Parti libéral, on e
lala reconnaît plus et c'est qud
mmême les partie qui a eu cette
ététiquette partie économique.
- - La CAQ fait cela!
- - Oui c'est pour cela
ququ'aujourd'hui elle a ciblé ce
memessage, en disant que son
memessage économique ne passait
papas.
S'S'est positionné comme un pari
dede gauche, vers, et elle n'a s
vrvraiment placé sa position
écéconomique.
- - Et si on élargit le cercle,l
n'n'y a pas maman, ses Jean-
FrFrançois Lisée que les Québécs
dede leur maman, donc les
QuQuébécois Franck le fun valeur
momoment Legault point
!!
CÇa fait quatre ans ou presque l
y y a aucun moment que la CAQ
asassemblée ébranlée, la confiae
esest maintenue à peu près de
fafaçon constante de même au cos
dedes derniers jours, il y a eu
dedes grosses attaques au sujet
dedes CHSLD, mais de façon
gégénérale les québécois ont déà
leleur opinion sur la gestion de
lala pandémie par l'acte.
ToTout le monde se dit que ça
s's'est mal passé dans les CHSL,
mamais au totale opinion des ges
esest positive et c'est pas pare
ququ'il y a un courriel du 8 avl
ququi est arrivé que ça va pas
chchanger les gens d'aider.
JeJe comprends que l'opposition
fafait son travail et travaille
fofort et les journalistes auss,
mamais ça n'ébranle pas la
coconfiance envers le gouvernemt
..
- - Luc, à partir du moment où l
y y a une symbiose ou une relatn
foforte entre le vote francophoe
etet Monsieur Legault, est
d'd'autant plus Mme Anglade ne
dedevrait pas être elle-même, ps
esessayé de se créer une nouvele
pepersonnalité?
- - Je pense que quoi qu'il fas,
c'c'est un moment difficile à
papasser pour les oppositions.
JeJe n'imagine pas le Parti
lilibéral disparaître, il va se
reresserrer sur quelques comtést
lele Parti québécois va aussi se
cocompter sur une base dans l'et
dudu Québec.
MaMais il faut reconnaître que
MoMonsieur Legault, ce n'est pas
ququ'il a connu le juste temps,l
esest chanceux, il s'appuie surn
enensemble de circonstances
écéconomiques jamais vu!
LeLe taux de chômage le plus bas
dede l'histoire, il y a des
pépénuries de main-d'oeuvre qui
foforce les employeurs à augmenr
leles salaires, alors que ce
n'n'était pas dans son programme
d'd'augmenter les salaires, mais
lala COVID a forcé le gouvernemt
àà procéder à des embauches
mamassives et à des bonificatios
dadans les CPE ou dans les
mamaternelles ou en éducation,
mamais ça ne faisait pas parti e
soson programme.
EnEn plus il est arrivé avec les
papages pleines parce qu'il est
ararrivé avec 10 milliards de
dodollars de surplus donné par e
gogouvernement libéral.
- - Et il était péquiste, donc l
pepeut nouer une relation de
coconfiance avec beaucoup du voe
nanationaliste, des gens qui se
didisent que de toute façon le
réréférendum n'arrivera pas demn
mamatin stock dont il ratisse
lalarge.
ToTo cover à quel genre de
cacampagne normale Québec dans x
momois.
PePetit mot sur le troisième lin
ququi se divise en deux, de pets
tutunnels?
OnOn recule, on fait le ménage?
- - Le projet dans sa forme
acactuelle, c'est à peu près
imimpossible pour Monsieur Legat
dede partir en campagne électore
avavec ce projet.
C'C'est un projet de 10 milliars
etet c'est le projet le plus grs
etet le plus cher et le plus
imimportant que la taxe a dans s
cacartons.
CeCe n'était même pas dans son
didiscours d'ouverture il y a
ququelques mois.
IlIl fallait absolument que ce
prprojet change et même à Québec
dadans les radios, si je peux me
pepermetettre, il y avait deux
bébémols consuls B, c'était les
prprix et la date de livraison,
202031!
- - Rapidement, je veux parler s
cacaribous avant de partir!
- - Sur les plans techniques si
fafaciliter, c'est prétentieux
prpresque infaisable, on ne sait
papas ce qu'on va découvrir sous
l'l', mais sur le fond ça ne
chchange pas grand-chose les
obobjections des fonds que les
gegens ont contre ce projet vont
dedemeurer.
- - Luc innue vous n'allez pas
apapplaudir?
- - Comment ça va fonctionner?
D'D'abord il y avait un projet
tutunnels et maintenant on chere
unune justification et maintenat
sasa forme, d'habitude c'est le
cocontraire!
- - La protection des caribous,.
GuGuilbeault a dit qu'il fallait
ququ'il s'attend avec Québec, et
ququ'est-ce qu'on comprend?
- - On comprend que le
gogouvernement de la CAQ tarde
paparce qu'il devait y avoir une
prprotection de caribous en 2019
etet je précise que le ministre
PiPierre Dufour n'est pas celui
ququi est le plus performant du
gogouvernement.
IlIl a reporté cela en 2021, etl
a a même décidé qu'il reportaità
nonouveau et finalement il a
cocommencé une consultation,
cocontinuer aujourd'hui, et cete
ststratégie devrait, on devrait
l'l'avoir un jour peut-être en
202024, donc dans un autre mandt
etet c'est sans compter que ce
miministère, la rumeur qui court
c'c'est qu'on pourrait le faire
exexploser, c'est-à-dire qu'on
enenverrait la forêt aux
reressources naturelles et qu'on
enenverrait les parcours
totouristes, donc ce qui r resta
dede ce projet?
- - Monsieur Legault a dit que a
prprenne un équilibre.
MiMichel David, disons que Québc
esest moins précis qu'Ottawa de
dédéfendre les caribous?
- - C'est Claire et Monsieur
DuDupont aura l'air moins précis
quque tout le monde dans son
gogouvernement de mettre la faue
avavec la forêt, c'est comme
memettre l'énergie avec
l'l'environnement, il y a un
coconflit d'intérêt patent.
EnEn plus ce n'est pas un bon
popoliticien, si on donne à Otta
l'l'occasion de mettre son nez -
dededans, c'est sûr qu'ils vont
sasauter sur l'occasion de mes
cecertaines personnes existent
heheureusement il y a des lois
cacanadiennes.
- - Les espèces menacées, c'estn
popouvoir que le Canada?
- - Oui c'est la troisième fois
quque le fédéral remonte les
brbretelles du provincial là-
dedessus.
IlIl y a eu le projet ou le
féfédéral avait imposé l'arrêt t
lala maintenant il y a les
cacaribous, les ministres Julien
n'n'avaient rien comprendre et à
rerefuser les projets et à
auaugmenter les droits de coupe
dadans les forêts anciennes en
didisant qu'à cause de la
chchenille, la tour deux
épépinettes, on doit donner plus
dede territoires de copeaux
enentreprises.
EtEt aujourd'hui il est question
d'd'arrêter les publicistes à,
TrTranscontinental dit que ça va
memettre fin au forestières, doc
onon a une occasion en or de
rereculer sur la déforestation,
nonous n'avons pas besoin de ces
ememplois de toute manière!
- - Vous êtes passionné, c'est
bobon!
LeLe comparer parler d